[Music]
with Beyonce her Vogue cover proof is
our Vogue cover it's proof of that and
the historic moment isn't lost on her
Destiny's Child sister Kelly Rowland
[Music]
I know you're proud of her definitely
when we see women of color on magazine
covers but they're gracing vogue and
it's about so pop culture driven and
this is what beauty is I'm extremely
excited for young girls of color to see
that and understand and know that you
are beautiful Queen B had creative input
on her photo spread that celebrates
female beauty and power Kelly was at the
premiere of Spike Lee's black clansmen
starring Denzel Washington son John
David Washington you ready for this
tonight my goodness this is the energies
in the air I'm his friend
let's get invited back John David plays
a detective trying to infiltrate the Ku
Klux Klan and I had a little surprise
for him we have a video a fan question
that we'd like to show you is there a
role you always wanted to play that you
never would tell your father about all
right cuz he might get back to him one
is okay well then what's the most Denzel
or pauletta thing about you continuing
to express love and care and give hugs
stuff like that mom and his daddy are
both great actors he has no bad he
sounds like Denzel that mean they need a
little bit fancy fantastic oh good to
hear and chasten
you